because jack drop like in the movie this  is a bit of heard about you that for  every movie you do mmm  you write and perform a theme song well  yeah I've seen Jumanji yeah and there  didn't appear to be any many of you the  movie hasn't been officially released  yet so it's not out of my time doing  something fun I gotcha  thank you thank you I'm getting a talk  for the first time  very long Stewart  I love these guys we were all kind of  messing around with a theme song and me  and Nick Jonas actually put the  finishing touches on it and we shot a  music video hopefully hoping to release  it soon but you want a little taste I  would be pleased yes there's me the only  time you hear it I don't know if it's  gonna make the final cut but it's a  pretty powerful Jumanji it's a jungle  inside your soul somewhere deep inside  at the end  survival your own legal plunge the jewel  inside say the name of the game